this is an image of I would call it the
patriarchy and it's a lovely image it's
God the Father and he's assimilated to
the Sun because well because
consciousness which is associated with
light is the Builder of culture and he
rules over the walled city and and so
he's the centering idea you might say
that that unites a culture that's
another way of looking at it and he's
got two hands I described them as
security and tyranny all together order
and you know if you're in a university
the U of T students complain about this
all the time there's 60,000 U of T's
students right they feel like numbers
they feel ignored and no wonder cuz
they're numbers and they are ignored
it's no wonder they didn't feel that way
you know and there's huge classes of
1,200 people and they get lost and they
think god that's a pretty evil structure
and and uncaring it's like yeah that's
exactly right but by the same token you
know you get to purchase four years of
intellectual freedom and you have all
these people who could at least in
principle teach you something and you
get an identity out of the deal and if
you have half a half a bit of sense
you're in the library trying to read
great things and maybe you're not quite
as dopey and useless when you come out
as you were when you went in and so it
takes with one hand and gives with the
other and you got to understand that
about your position in relationship to
society it crushes you and molds you at
the same time it limits you and furthers
your capability at the same time and
it's up to you to determine how to
establish a harmonious and productive
relationship with that because that's
one of the fundamental demands of life
that sort of splits into these two
things but that's the king who devours
his son I love that picture and that's
well that's a society that's become
tyrannical right and the son of the king
is the thing that regenerates the King
the King's old and he's blind and he's
stupid and he's corrupt and he has a son
and the son is lively and awake and
alert and can see and if the father's
not pathological then he tries to make
the Sun strong so that this son can grow
up and revitalize the culture and if
he's a tyrant well then he devours him
and then he gets old and corrupt and
everything goes into chaos and then
there's the benevolent
King who's got that properly balanced in
UCD in this picture he's got a globe at
his hand with the cross on top of it and
that's means the same thing that of that
other symbolic image did which is that
the proper society supports the
suffering individual in his or her
attempts to transcend their suffering
and attain a proper ethical perspective
and then the son of the Father is the
hero that's Hercules I really like that
picture so Hercules goes out into the
darkness and he's got this container and
maybe you can think of that container as
a cultural artifact you know because the
culture protects you from chaos and then
the question is what are you supposed to
do with that protection and the answer
is you're supposed to wear the garb of
the lion right that's the king of the
beasts so that's supposed to be you and
you're supposed to go out there into the
darkness with your bloody eyes open so
you can discover what's in the darkness
and share with everyone else and he's
got a club there in his hands and the
club is covered with eyes those are eyes
NOT barbs and what that means is that
you should bloody well pay attention and
that well the other element of that
that's not expressed in that image is
that you should also speak carefully pay
attention and speak carefully and then
you're the proper son of the proper
father and you can keep things
functioning and that makes you into this
right so the city is always threatened
it's always corrupt and threatened and
there's always something outside that's
going to take it down always and that's
what's represented by the dragon that
little twist in its tail is something
that represents infinity and the
courageous individual goes out of the
damaged city to confront the dragon of
chaos and to gain something valuable as
a consequence and that's what human
beings are supposed to do that's our
destiny that's our soul that's a better
way of thinking about it and some of
that terrible dragon is just the
catastrophe and suffering of life and
our continual attempts to transcendent
but a tremendous amount of it is also
the malevolence and the evil that exists
in our own hearts and in society and
perhaps to some degree even in the world
itself you're supposed to wake up and
strengthen yourself and stand up
properly and fortify yourself so that
you're a light that can shine in the
darkness and that's something that can
withstand malevolence and tragedy
and what's your alternative you're gonna
let life crush you and make you weak and
make you resentful and bitter and then
murderous you'll take out your rage on
everyone you can and it'll only be
limited by your capacity to obtain power
that's not a good thing and so it's this
way or it's this way or a way that leads
directly to hell and we've certainly
seen that plenty of times in the last
hundred years and you'd think we might
have learned our lesson but it takes a
lot for people to learn and we're in
danger of repeating exactly the same
mistakes again
so you know it's one thing to complain
about the political polarization and
it's another thing to point fingers at
the post modernists and the neo-marxist
even though they they roundly deserve it
in my estimation it's another thing to
try to figure out what the proper
alternative is and the proper
alternative is not in my estimation to
contribute to political polarization
it's not good and it's not that the
radical right is the solution to the
radical left it's just another
catastrophe and the only solution that
I've been able to figure out and this is
as a consequence of much reading and
much thinking is that it's up to the
individuals in our society sort
themselves out and to strengthen
themselves and to become wise and alert
and to shoulder the responsibility of
being and the demand the ethical demand
to push back malevolence in their own
hearts and in their society and I also
believe that you know it's very
difficult for people to respect
themselves because they're weak and
vulnerable and pathetic and malevolent
and so it's no and they're not what they
could be and they know it and so it's no
wonder that people don't respect
themselves and some of that's nature and
some of that's culture and some of its
individual weakness but one of the
things that I've learned and it's about
the only optimistic thought I've ever
come across is that if you have enough
courage to forthrightly accept the fact
that you're vulnerable and malevolent
and you're willing to do something about
it to overcome it you can develop enough
respect for yourself so that the
terrible weight of being will not make
you malevolent and corrupt and I don't
think that you have anything better to
aim for unless you want blood in the
streets in a pathetic life and so you
might as well straighten up and get your
together and maybe we've got some chance
of getting through this intermediary
period of chaos that we all face and
make something better out of it instead
of something worse so that's what I have
to say about that
so thank you
[Applause]